we see these kind of dumb guy on the
street interviews that everybody does
now you find them all over YouTube and
we find in these videos that people uh
it's really easy to find people who know
absolutely nothing apparently do you
know what country Hawaii is in Kauai is
a country and we want to tell ourselves
when we see those videos that it's kind
of cherry picking but I I actually think
tragically and uh in a quite terrifying
way that those videos offer a pretty
accurate picture of American culture at
this at this point this is the most
educated Society that's ever existed
almost any 20 year old that you come
across had at least 13 years of formal
education and then Millions more went on
for advanced what's supposed to be
Advanced higher education uh it's quite
unprecedented in history to have a to
have a a culture that is so educated on
paper and that's why it should actually
be very difficult to go out in public
and find grown adults who know nothing
at all but it's not